tis the season for Time Warner owner of
Turner Broadcasting owner of the Metro
Goldwyn Meyers pre-1986 film library to
pump your household full of a Christmas
story for 24 hours straight let's talk
about how a Christmas story is
technological nostalgia yearning for a
prelapsarian world by definition
fictional encapsulated in material
objects as signifier of the age of
innocence a false memory of a time that
never truly existed implanted in the
collective video form through corporate
repetition I love Christmas so much I
[Music]
don't think a Christmas story is a
particularly good movie and I've
honestly never liked it as a child I
found it boring and obnoxious my
feelings towards it have softened a bit
watching it as an adult I can appreciate
the craft now better than I could as a
kid and in particular I think Peter
Billingsley is quite talented as a
physical actor especially for a child
actor but overall seeing it through
adult eyes hasn't actually improved my
opinion of the movie as much as it has
shifted the nature of what I dislike
about it
a Christmas Story advertising itself as
a tribute to the original traditional
100% red-blooded two-fisted All American
Christmas was released in 1983 to
lukewarm reception before fighting an
audience through the 80s and 90s in
increasingly frequent televised
broadcasts escalating to the point that
in 1997 Turner Broadcasting shortly
after being bought out by Time Warner
began airing a 24 hour marathon over
Christmas Eve and Christmas Day on TBS
the film consists of Ralphie as an adult
recounting what he frames as a
particularly memorable Christmas from
his early 1940s childhood a technique
that would get recycled in similar
nostalgia driven properties The Wonder
Years and the very very strange Tom
Hanks film Radio Flyer
Michael is getting worse why is this
happening to bombing me not to me
ba-ba-back damn I gotta talk about Radio
Flyer someday the story here plays out
in a series of loose vignettes mostly
centering around nine-year-old Ralphie's
desire to get a Red Rider carbine action
200 shot range model air rifle for
Christmas his attempts to persuade the
adults around him and various other
incidental episodes cynically the film's
version of the original traditional 100%
red-blooded two-fisted All American
Christmas manifests largely as
technological nostalgia the films I is
like Ralphie particularly obsessed with
material things and how they used to be
the children in the opening montage
stand outside Hades department store
looking and wonder at what the adult
Ralphie narrates as mechanized
electronic joy a montage of an
animatronic miss Claus electric trains
puttering along on their tracks and
wind-up tin tanks that drive themselves
several scenes with Ralphie's old man
hinged their humor on his father's
combat with the household furnace and
electrical systems with one gag in
particular relying on knowing what this
device is and how it works
Ralphie and his brother crowd around the
radio to listen to Little Orphan Annie
serials in a particularly memorable
scene endlessly referenced by later
works
Ralphie finally receives his Little
Orphan Annie secret decoder pen ecstatic
to be a part of the privileged Little
Orphan Annie inner circle but comes to
the sad realization that he's being sold
a bill of goods as the evening secret
message decodes to be sure to drink your
Ovaltine a plug for the show's sponsor
as Ralphie says all that for a crummy
commercial and Ovaltine and Little
Orphan Annie aren't alone Oldsmobile
Raggedy Ann Red Ryder Radio Flyer The
Wizard of Oz Mickey Mouse Lux Palmolive
and oxydol are all placed or referenced
the original traditional 100%
red-blooded two-fisted all-american
Christmas is unabashedly a Christmas of
things and brands the oddity of this
particular brand of nostalgia is that it
makes a Christmas story a movie
about kids but only nominally for kids
the focus is not on the world as
children perceive it but on the
childhood world remembered by adults the
iconography the references the physical
space the film doesn't resemble the
world children exist in and it never did
already by 1983 a nine-year-old had no
point of reference for an extended joke
about the furnace damper it is a movie
nebulously set in a very distinct time
that explicitly looks with fondness on
the materials of a childhood already 40
years distant at the time of its
construction and that fact that it is a
period piece certainly does help to make
the film feel older than it really is
feel like it is part of some tradition
that has survived generations this all
ties in to why I think the film did
poorly in theaters but better on
television television adds to the slight
of hand
disguises aged movies that were on TV in
the 80s and 90s were by definition no
longer brand new it is structurally
poorly suited for watching in a theater
anyway but perfectly suited for playing
in the background while everyone bustles
around the house doing holiday stuff the
film drones along while everyone
chatters until someone notices the
screen and says hey everyone here's the
best part
and then recites their favorite joke in
rough sync with the film before going
back to the snack table to get more
punch the fact that the movie is so
structuralist makes it somewhat perfect
for TNT's 24-hour looping marathon it
just kind of ends at the end of the film
the neighbor's dogs eat the dinner
turkey and the family ends up instead at
the bowling & Sons chop suey palace
company for a painfully long joke
revolving around Chinese accents and the
song deck the halls'
what can I say but
yikes after their dinner of duck that's
pretty much it the family tucks away for
the night Ralphie and Randy clutching
their things and the credits roll
unlike most holiday fare there's no
moral no lessons no affirmation of human
goodness or appeals to the better softer
nature of mankind it is a story about a
child who gets a toy and little more
it's about that one year when a lot
happened none of it meant anything be
sure to drink your Ovaltine I don't
think the movie is a particularly good
movie but is a darkly perfect match for
the medium of television a handful of
memorable scenes competently executed
strung together in a way that actually
improves more the less you pay attention
however I don't think the medium change
alone tells the whole story of the
film's reassessment and rise in
popularity the shift from the big screen
to the small the mode of engagement
changing from being confined in a
theater to drifting in and out between
chores all of this is substantial but it
isn't the entire picture
autobiographically I was actually
shocked when I realized this movie came
out after I was born it had in my mind
as a child always being there and loved
and quoted as it was by my parents in
some level of my consciousness I had
assumed it was as old as they were from
the nebulous before time preceding my
existence it is instead a little younger
than me and merely laser focused on my
parents and their memories of childhood
as the 50s in rural Canada were not so
different from the urban 40s the movies
rise in popularity however doesn't
explode until the late 90s until people
who were young enough to see a Christmas
story as children were old enough to
associate the movie directly with their
own childhoods old enough for the movie
to become their own object of nostalgia
it should be noted too that the
conditions for that association are in
their own way as artificial as the
products Ralphie covets in 1985
metro-goldwyn-mayer was purchased by Ted
Turner who was looking to secure their
substantial back catalog of films as
held assets
for his wtbs superstation the following
year turner sold off every component
part of MGM except the pre 1986 film
library
this gave Turner a huge library of films
to exploit for broadcast as Turner
Entertainment could license the MGM
films to Turner Broadcasting for
functionally noting the proliferation of
Christmas Story in addition to a number
of other films has as much to do with
the cost for broadcasters to license
them as it does their actual popularity
this is why actually really popular in
successful Christmas movies like home
alone elf and the Santa Clause are only
occasionally on broadcast
well the objectively kind of bad
rankin/bass Rudolph the red-nosed
reindeer has aired more or less
uninterrupted since 1964 so a movie that
saw a middling reception with its
release in 1983 gained new life in 1986
as the functionally free holiday filler
for Turner Broadcasting but didn't
really gain true popularity until the
maturation of a generation of children
who had seen it as children and those
people had seen it as children because
it was on TV where it was a filler movie
that stations could readily license and
the synergistic surge in popularity was
then capitalized on by TBS who could
afford to air the movie as many times as
they wanted because they owned it the
tradition of a Christmas story it's true
roots as a phenomenon of the season the
history of the 24-hour marathon isn't a
deep-rooted cultural practice it's a
corporate stunt that's younger than men
in black childhood nostalgia is a tricky
thing and should always be handled with
some skepticism children by and large
lack the means and capacity to seek out
to curate to filter in the 80s you
watched what you did because that's what
was on TV whether it was the decision of
our parents or the person doing the
scheduling of the network our childhoods
were programmed for us it is altogether
fitting that a Christmas story a story
of nostalgia for things wasn't able to
succeed until the film itself became the
object of nostalgia when it could become
the self-contained symbol
of childhood Christmases the e vocation
of sitting around a 12-inch tube
television watching movies and running
to the bathroom during commercial breaks
but to me I'm Ralphie sitting around the
radio scratching away with my decoder
pen only to realize that the message at
the core of my childhood entertainment
well it's just a crummy commercial